these decisions about whether to marry
who to marry whether their children
where to Live Career what kind of a
friend to be these are decisions that
capture who we are they're much more
than just the sum of everyday Pleasure
and Pain that I accumulate through the
course of living and if I only take that
perspective I'm going to miss out on the
overarching things that I think matter
dignity self-respect living the way one
should live aspiring becoming the person
you want to become I think if you only
focus on the narrow pleasures and pains
you'll miss out on on some of these
bigger things
as an economist
how do they typically assess decision
making in humans what's the framework
that an economist looks at decisions
through
the framework is one that I've often
advocated for in my youth when I was
less wise I suppose but this it's a
pretty uh standard framework and it
makes a lot of sense it's that you have
a five-night amount of money you have a
finite amount of time and you have
infinite wants you have all the stuff
that you enjoy and you'd like more of
everything but you can't have all you
want can't always get what you want and
that's because you don't have an
infinite amount of money so the goal of
life is to get the most out of it and
the way we do that is we we balance off
the pleasure we get from this good
versus the pleasure we get from that
good and we pick how much we want to
consume of these goods and services
based on our limited resources and it's
a formal maximization problem it's a
calculus problem the goal is to
accumulate as much pleasure as possible
and pleasure doesn't just mean uh days
at the beach and and gluttonous meals it
includes subtle satisfactions as well in
the hands of a skilled Economist but the
goal in life is to is to be happy where
happiness can have some real texture to
it uh if we're thoughtful about it you
said that that was something you used
when you were younger why has that
framework been eroded over time
trouble dealing with some of the things
that I've come to think are quite
important it struggles and I should add
as a footnote before I start that there
were probably a handful of economists
who wouldn't struggle to include these
things I'm talking about the average
Economist uh and the average person
who's who's drunk The Economist Kool-Aid
and has uh used these techniques for for
their for their own lives let's talk
about what's missing from that one of
the things that's missing is other
people
now in my earlier work as a scholarly
academic I tried to build models of
Charity and obviously there are parts of
charitable giving where you get pleasure
from it and that fits very nicely into
the economist toolkit uh it implies
things like uh if you make charity tax
deductible if it and it wasn't before
people give more because you've lowered
the price of giving money to someone
else it's a bit sterile right it's a bit
sterile but it can be fitted to the
framework but what about my wife how
should I think about my wife's happiness
is my wife's happiness something that
makes me happy if I am kind to her is
that do I do that because I enjoy being
nice to her because then she'll be nice
to me is it all about
keeping score which is sort of The
Economist framework and I'd suggest it's
not
um a life well lived a marriage well
executed and and lived is not about
keeping score I shouldn't be thinking
about what's in it for me all the time
The Economist model is what's in it for
me and you can broaden it to say well
one of the things that said it for me is
what's in it for you makes me happy but
again I think that's kind of a little
bit sterile doesn't really capture the
full way we think about most of us think
about being nice to other people and how
about decisions that my wife and I make
together
um how do I think about my happiness her
happiness the morality of it
do we take turns
um that's not the right way most people
live and most importantly most of the
things that really bring deep and
abiding satisfaction as opposed to
momentary pleasure most of the things
that bring us deep and abiding
satisfaction don't fit so well into the
model dignity sense of self autonomy
mattering that people think and respect
you these are things that you can cram
them into the economist toolkit but not
very easily one of the reasons is that
they overlay the entire experience of
life I argue in the in my book
they give texture to Everyday Life in it
this very different from the texture of
well that was a good ice cream cone
should I have a second one well they're
585 a piece now I won't well that's a
rational economics decision but
the Deep deeper questions of you know
moral dilemmas what should I do with my
life should I get married should I have
children these don't fit into the
economist toolkit it's not all about
cost-benefit analysis on a day-to-day
basis
and so that's where I've kind of uh part
a company in some sense I think most
economists would recognize whether I
don't want to be a create a straw person
that you know economists would say there
are some but cannabis would say I should
maximize your satisfaction for your
marriage and that means if you can get
away without taking out the garbage or
doing the dishes or you can watch the
movie you want for sure
yeah they're economists who do that most
economists know that that economics has
some limitations in what it applies to
um
and so then the question is what's left
what do we do for rational decisions in
these tough areas so that's that's kind
of the starting point for for my book
evolutionary psychology would say the
reason that you want to be selfless to
other people is for ultimately selfish
ends reciprocal altruism you would be
pushing your own genetic fitness they
will owe you I learned this amazing
Insight which you may be familiar with
or may not about why we feel sympathy
for people so sympathy is investment
advice the reason being that someone
that is unbelievably down on their luck
will be disproportionately appreciative
of even the smallest amount of
investment that you give to them the
reason why your heartstrings are pulled
when you see a homeless guy in the
street who has no shoes and two pence to
his name because you know that two pens
to him would be so much whereas two pens
to the millionaire down the road would
not and it is one of the tensions that I
think we'll probably talk about is this
difference between knowing yourself
knowing the world understanding the
principles that things are based upon
and then
transcending them like realizing that
the principles and the Artistry of life
kind of have to flow together in a way
where if you look at them through too
much of a utilitarian rationalistic
perspective where you've got an expected
value outcome proposition on the other
side of it
you end up removing the joy of the
decision itself because I think
integrity and a sense of faith in your
own character comes about from making
decisions Beyond simply a rational
framework that you go through it's
something that's emergent it applies it
comes out of you because you wanted to
do it because you have imbibed the right
principles that turn you into the sort
of person you want to be as opposed to
your desires clashing up against some
external framework that you always need
to be funneled down
well I I would say a little differently
I I would say that happiness is one of
those things that's best pursued in a
roundabout way
if you can have a vacation and you say
wow I gotta get the most out of my
vacation
or
um
and what am I going to do not to make
myself really happy and of course some
of those things you have to discover and
they're not things you're going to plan
that's the part that you're saying that
I agree with very much this city of
emergence
um it's it's the irony that some goals
are best achieved by not thinking about
the goals
and the the other part though is that
economists because of their
they're not careful because of their
their
um
their commitment to the model
the model is only an idea for trying to
understand the complexity of human life
but if you take it a little too
seriously you can put yourself in the
following situation it's an example it's
not in the book
um I think it illustrates it nicely so
you invite me over for dinner and I
think you know that was really nice of
Chris to have us but we should we should
bring something
uh now you might ask the question of why
we would even think of doing that right
you're having a so for dinner why would
I why would I think of bringing
something I mean you're giving me a gift
this in a way negates the gift
but this is cultural norm okay so I my
wife says
I was freaking bottle of wine and I
think you know I think we're having it's
dinner it'll probably be some red wine
will probably be appropriate so she
suggests a bottle of red wine and I
being the foolish economist
say you know
you might not like wine as much as we do
and instead of bringing the bottle of
wine I think he's why I'm sure he's got
one prepared for the dinner he's not
counting on us
just bring him a 20 bill
so that way he can get the most out of
it because the 20 bill can buy the 20
say it's a 20 bottle of wine he could
buy a 20 bottle of wine with if he wants
but if he'd like something more than the
20 bill
than the wine excuse me if you like
something more than the wine he could
buy that instead so to give him the wine
is inefficient we can produce more
happiness for the world but give them
the 20 bill
and most wives unless they've been
married to economists for a long time go
what the heck are you talking about
what's wrong aren't you a human being
there's a norm that you don't bring
money to somebody's house
and I'll say is the stupid Economist
yeah but the wine is like money even if
I do bring the wine I'm still paying him
back something so at least let's pay him
back with something he can it'll get the
most out of
but most people would go like well
that's stupid why would you do that
because it's not gracious so you might
ask a deeper question why is it a
gracious what's the economist missing
there and one we could talk about that
for the whole rest of the time but one
of the things the economists missing is
that there's certain expectations that
have been set up for social experience
you know be like me saying well you know
in my experience at dinner parties they
work best with people
take turns talking and nobody really
talks more than say 53 percent of the
time so I'm just going to let you know
that while you're talking at dinner I'll
be keeping a stopwatch
to make sure you don't take more than
your fair share and because I'm a good
person I'll be doing that for myself as
well
yes sir
bad ideas but they're the reductoid
absurdum of where you end up if you take
too seriously this notion of getting the
most out of every opportunity and The
Economist toolkit is quite useful in
many settings I think the kind of
settings we're talking about it leads to
um
social faux pas
and then scaling these problems up to
the bigger ones about
where to live about whether or not to
marry how many children to have how
self-centered to be these are what
you've termed as wild problems which
have bigger externalities and last for
longer and are more serious but they
kind of run along similar lines that
trying to do the expected value
calculator for them is going to end up
in a challenging place I give a lot of
examples of why that's the case you know
uh but to take your first point the
subtitle of the book is a guide to the
decisions that Define us
these decisions about whether to marry
who to marry whether their children
where to Live Career what kind of a
friend to be these are decisions that
capture Who We Are they're much more
than just the sum of everyday Pleasure
and Pain that I accumulate through the
course of living and if I only take that
perspective I'm going to miss out on the
the overarching things I mentioned
earlier that I think matter dignity
self-respect
um a feeling of of of being living the
way one should live aspiring becoming
the person you want to become I think if
you only focus on the narrow pleasures
and pains the way the economist tool
kitchens really pushes you you'll miss
out on on some of these bigger things
but of course the other point is is that
you can't really do a rational
calculation on becoming a parent when
you realize that becoming a parent
changes what you care about so who
should you take into account the you
before you have kids at the U after you
have kids and so that's um that's
another piece of it
what should people rely on if they're
not using more data in that case what
what else is there so I
the you know the narrow definition I go
with these wow problems so these are
problems where it's not just you can't
do a cost-benefit analysis uh you don't
have the kind of information you need to
make a rational decision you can't
really imagine
remotely what it's like to be a parent
or a a spouse a little bit with a spouse
but a parent you really can't uh what
it's like to live in a foreign country
uh what it's like to live an ethical
life these are things that you learn
about as you experience them you make
sacrifices for example of day-to-day
pleasure and get something else uh so
now what you know that's that's great
okay so you've ruined my day you know I
can't make a rational decision I don't I
can't use an algorithm I don't have an
app on my phone uh what do I do and the
answer you know I suggest that since
these are the decisions that Define us
you might want to think about who you
want to be you know if they Define Who
You Are
you to answer that question you have to
think about who you want to be to figure
out who you want to be you have to give
some thought
to what you care about and what you
might care about if you were different
what you might care about if you grew
what you might care about if you reach
Beyond who you are now to be something
maybe better greater
could be more ambitious but it could be
more ethical it could be more meaningful
or more purposeful it could be you
accomplish something you would otherwise
neglect or Miss if you focused on that
only on the day-to-day
in the book I I spent I think a whole
paragraph
only a paragraph on the different ways
that you might explore those questions
obviously
uh many many books of many many volumes
have been written on who you might want
to become
the standard roots for getting there the
paragraph version is well you could go
into therapy
because you have trouble actually seeing
who you are you could try religion which
forces you to transcend yourself you
could meditate which although it seems
self-centered I think often leads us to
be able to stand outside ourselves and
observe what uh
triggers us pushes us
uh and you can read great literature
which I think helps us understand the
human heart
so those are the roots to go but my
book's not about that the question then
is okay so I have to give some thought
to where I want to go but how do I cope
with the fact that I can't use my tools
I can't use my cross-benefit analysis I
can't make my Pro con list and so most
the second half of the book is is trying
to give people uh various ideas for how
to frame these decisions you know to
recognize that there's no right decision
many people find that comforting we're
so obsessed I got to find not just the
right this is the best decision I find
the best outcome I gotta maximize
optimize rid of the life hacks give me
give me the 10 best ways to find a
spouse the 10 best ways to decide
whether to have a child and they aren't
there so you have to think about
would it be like to live in a world
where you're unmoored from the
techniques and tools that you've become
accustomed to using and so some of the
book is trying to give you
um ease and and Solace over what I think
is a reality that you will make many
what are will be called mistakes if
you're not careful but are actually just
part of the natural process of living
because you can't see the future so why
would you feel guilty that you couldn't
make the best decision when you didn't
have any data I mean that's not a
mistake that's life
I fell in love with a concept called
release the tiller which is from Jed
McKenna and the tiller is the thing
that's attached to the rudder on the
back of the boat and his argument is
that a lot of the time while people try
to control their life they grip the
tiller harder and harder yeah they they
grip it with Fury and he says that one
of the best ways is to just release the
tiller to just allow yourself to have
ease and I ended up realizing a bunch of
situations that people get themselves
into myself first and foremost one of
them being that
the more that I try and apply cognitive
horsepower to the decisions that I need
to make
a lot of the time the less effective the
decisions are the more painful they are
to go through because I I put all of the
onus
somewhere it's kind of like the Paradox
of choice if only if only if only I'd
had a better model more more time or
whatever to do the thing as opposed to
realizing that every single person
that's listening to this podcast right
now no matter what the challenges are
that they came up against the neuroses
the overthinking the complete the the
sleepless nights of not being able to
believe that they could get through this
thing if they're listening to this
podcast right now by that fact it means
that they've got through whatever the
challenges are you have however many
years or decades that you've been alive
of proof that every single challenge
that you thought would destroy you or
take you to the the edge of this
destruction and despair
has not managed to do it right you have
you are the survival of all of those
challenges and yet because of negativity
bias and loss aversion and all of that
sort of stuff we look to the Future
still with this same degree of fragility
and I think that I I think that the fact
that we've got through all of that is
super important uh you used as an
illustrative example one of my favorite
stories from history which is Darwin's
marriage and how he how he went through
that and I've got a little description
that I took out the first book I ever
learned about it in which was the moral
Animal by Robert Wright from 1993. so in
the decade of Darwin's marriage the
1830s the number of British couples
filing for divorce averaged four per
year
foreign
that's not in thousands that's just four
four
I mean the population will be a bit
lower but it's not it's the marriage is
significantly lower than the population
is lower so uh Darwin the uh ever the
rationalist and the self-assessor he was
a man that seemed to be quite um
troubled with uh his own motivations I
think he was his degree of analysis and
attention and assessment of other
creatures also got turned inward on
himself too uh and he journals he
journaled very frequently so it meant
that he has this journal which we now
have access to and he is trying to make
this decision about whether to marry or
not the document has two columns one
labeled marry one labeled not marry and
above them circled other words this is
the question on the pro-marriage side of
the equation were children if it pleased
God constant companion and friend in old
age who will feel interested in one
objects to be beloved and played with
after reflection of an unknown length he
modified the foregoing sentence with
better than a dog anyhow
he continued home and someone to take
care of the house charms of music and
female Chit Chat these things good for
one's Health but terrible loss of time
without warning Darwin had from the
pro-marriage column swerved
uncontrollably into major anti-marriage
factors so major that he underlined it
this issue the infringement of marriage
on his time especially his work time was
addressed at greater length in the
appropriate not to marry column not
marrying he wrote Would preserve freedom
to go where one likes choice of society
and little of it conversation of clever
men at clubs not forced to visit
relatives and to Bent in every trifle to
have the expense and anxiety of children
perhaps quarreling loss of time cannot
read in the evening fatness and idleness
anxiety and responsibility less money
for books and if many children forced to
gain one's bread what an unbelievable
example of somebody trying to use those
Frameworks in order to come up with a
big life decision
yeah uh what I suggest
first point of course is as I argue is
that if you look at those two columns
it's pretty clear what the right choice
is uh not enough time to read do your
work and missing the clever conversation
in clubs with with men uh and what do
you get in return female Chit Chat and
something that's better than a dog
anyhow it's
thin soup uh it's pretty clear that the
right choice for Darwin is not to marry
and underlying of course all that loss
of time I think is his word that he will
not achieve his scientific Legacy
Kafka by the way as as I recount in the
book makes a similar list and he decides
not to marry which is very rational
based on his list but Darwin despite his
list marries and at the end of having
made those two columns he then writes
this stream of Consciousness paragraph
which is basically oh my God I'll be
alone in my old age coming back to a
Digi apartment Mary Mary and he's
marries and he marries I think about six
months later mayor's cousin uh and he um
I don't think she was planned as the
person in the back of his mind I think
he just went out and found her footnote
fascinating
um
she would read to him every night and he
actually liked it so even though he was
doing his own reading at night he did
get uh he did come to like the
alternative that he was able to have
through marriage but the question is
what was he thinking there I mean in the
calm sober light of day he puts up the
costs and the benefits and it's pretty
clear marriage is a loser
but embarrassed anyway and I think you
know there's a lot of things you could
say about that decision you could argue
social norms kind of pushed him in that
direction I'm sure they did but I like
to think and what what I expanded on the
book I like to think that he understood
there was more at stake than the
day-to-day pleasures of and pains of of
married life
um there was meaning and there was
satisfactions he could only imagine and
he really couldn't imagine because he
had no access to them he surely knew no
one articulate about marriage who could
explain it to him he might have read a
great novel he could have read Jane
Austen and maybe if he did I don't know
if he read Austin but and I think she'd
already written sensibility say or other
books by that time but didn't really
have who's going to explain it and think
about your own for those who out there
who are married I'd explain to someone
what's good and bad about marriage the
bad's pretty clear most people I think
could list what's bad about marriage
like like Darwin was worried about the
downside he had really no access to the
upside the same would be to her children
from the outside children looks like
pretty
bad decisions I mean really
all the expense and the time and the
nuisance and they get sick and they're
worried about this they would die and
and they did
um it's hard
and yet most people have children is is
that irrational or is there something
else going on there and I think the
certainly the
until you've had children your access to
the inner life of Parenthood is limited
uh it's not for everybody it's not like
it's a day at the park it's not uh but
it adds a texture to your life that is
unattainable and other very difficult to
attain I would say it other ways it adds
a meaningfulness and a purpose of just a
life and I think Darwin probably
understood that somewhere when they
didn't write it down maybe not I don't
know how is that similar to the choice
about whether or not to become a vampire
so the vampire idea comes from the
philosopher L.A Paul of Yale University
and her book transformative experiences
that I Riff on in my book uh you know a
vampire
if you talk to vampires they're really
happy they like
flitting about at night and freaking
blood and
sleeping in a coffin and those must be
Immortals we look at that and go like
that sounds kind of creepy I don't think
I'd like that and yet everyone almost
everyone maybe maybe all of them think
it's a great way to live and they look
back on their feeble and thin lives as
humans with disgust and disdain
so now what do you do you take the leap
if you do there's no going back right
and some decisions in life
are literally like that there's no going
back it's very hard to go back from
being a parent it's very hard to it's
costly to go back from being married but
you can go back and get a divorce if you
move to a place you turn out you don't
like you can go back but Thomasville
said you can't go home again he was I
think onto something right it's easy to
say you can go back but it's actually
quite emotionally complicated uh many
decisions in life and we're talking
about a handful of decisions marriage
children career what kind of friend to
be is a little bit different but many of
these decisions they have a uh
irreversibility about them they're a bit
of a one-way leap it's harder to LEAP
back you can sometimes and you can do it
sometimes at a cost and I argue later
that if you know the cost is relatively
small you should do more leaping you can
go back it's okay nothing to be ashamed
of I think a lot of times there's a more
this worry that oh I'll look foolish I
had to I changed my mind why is that is
that embarrassing it's not it's okay
it's like saying I bought about I bought
the wrong stereo in the old days so I
wrote I bought a bad car or I picked a
bad college or whatever it is and
it's okay to transfer it's okay right
nothing shameful there but a lot of
times I think we're emotionally very
it's very awkward because we don't want
to reveal to other people that quote we
made a mistake and you know I suggested
the book it's okay it's not a mistake
really
does a
topic that I have fallen in love with
called anxiety cost so you'll be
familiar with opportunity cost right
which is by doing a thing you can't do
another thing anxiety cost is the mental
effort that is taken up considering the
thing that you are yet to do which could
have been gotten rid of by simply doing
the thing so every morning when you wake
up your daily routine starts and you
have to meditate and walk the dog and
and do whatever else it is that you do
and the longer that you wait during the
day to do that the more time you spend
thinking about having to do it whereas
had you have done it earlier you reduce
what I've termed anxiety cost nice bro
science Economist over here I love that
what I realized with regards to the
anxiety cost is that closing the loop
right getting rid of that zygonic effect
wherever you can
is a good opportunity on average it
seems like people that make decisions
end up being happier people enjoy just
making decisions and having change so if
you are faced with two relatively
similar options especially one which is
reversible and moving this is one that
I've been playing with for a long time
because I recently moved to America and
I got this visa and it was a big thing
and I'm in a country on my own doing
this podcast thing and God knows how
that's going to go
and yet
I ended up going and doing it and I
adored it I adored the decision I
absolutely loved it I know that you
recently made the jump to go to Israel I
think yeah
and I I everything is everything's
exciting and new and if I want to move
back and even if I messed up even if I
messed up and I came back with egg on my
face
I genuinely think getting back into the
economist's thought process that the
discomfort of having to admit publicly
that I I made a go of this and it didn't
work out
would be less painful than living with
the anxiety cost of the what if
had I not done it well I don't totally
agree with that I like the anxiety cost
idea
uh I think I would have been totally
happy if I'd not moved to Israel doing
whatever what I was doing before which
was very pleasant uh it's true I would
have had that what if but I would have
forgotten about it I would have pushed
it down and tried not to dwell on it
because it's it's in the past
um you also moved to a country where
they speak more or less the same
language
uh Israel's a lot harder they speak
Hebrew here there are a number of people
who speak English but uh cultural
transition I think between the United
States and Israel uh and England the
United States is is trickier
um I took what you were saying
differently and tell me if ever I got
this wrong I like this anxiety cost idea
because it says
you need surgery
and you can have it now or you can have
it in six weeks what do you want a lot
of people would say
I don't want it now I'll do it in six
weeks and then you have six weeks of
Torment pull the Band-Aid off do it now
get it done now it's true you could die
that'd be a negative and you could have
had the six weeks of life in between
before the surgery so that it's a little
bit uh more complicated but the idea
that procrastination is a uh a malaise a
a
um an unhealthy thing and we justify it
by saying I'll just get more information
or in the case maybe I'll recover before
the surgery I won't need it at all right
we have all these stories we might tell
ourselves to avoid short-term pain I
have a different track uh see what you
think of this one
uh I believe
or I'm chair of psychologist
that
pleasure remains much longer in our
memories than pain
so if you go on a great vacation
you're going to savor it
uh and you'll be able to enjoy it for
years because you'll be able to look
back on and say remember that that was
so much fun and we did this and and you
have the photographs whereas the root
canal
so over I don't think about it you say
how bad was that rooted oh my gosh it
was horrible
I had a bad one I've had good ones Since
By the way which I dreaded but they
turned out to be fine I was wrong to
dread them but I should have dreaded
them for the reason I'm saying now which
is like really do you look back on it
and say oh it was horrible there you
don't you didn't even think about it uh
and so
get through it do it now do the painful
thing now and and enjoy more of the
pleasurable thing because the algorithm
you know the I'll get more information
about whether I really need the
operation that's a bad trick that's a
that's a false trick it's not good for
you
is your brain playing a bad a bad life
hack
the opposite of the anxiety cost which
you can leverage to have more enjoyment
in life is the anticipation effect so
you Tim Ferriss does this and I love
doing this as well have holidays booked
two years three years in advance right
because a big chunk of the enjoyment of
the holiday before you get the sand
between your toes and the you got the
cocktail that was Blended not not on the
rocks and it's a bit hotter than you
expected it's the anticipation of it so
you can reverse the anxiety cost with
the anticipation effect and what you
just said there I think is an example of
fading affect bias the goodness and
Badness of memories fade over time but
the Badness Fades faster some bad
memories even become good memories while
good memories rarely become bad ones it
makes sense that both joint pain Fade
with Time stuff just feels less intense
when it's farther away but why does pain
fade faster it's because when bad stuff
happens to us our psychological immune
systems turn on we start to rationalize
why would I want to be with someone who
doesn't want to be with me we downplay
breakups happen all the time in high
school it's no big deal we distance I
never liked her that much anyway and we
distract I'm gonna go and play video
games these mental processes function
like emotional antibodies taking the
sting out of bad memories we don't use
them on good memories so good memories
keep their luster longer everything is
temporary bad stuff especially tragedy
plus time equals comedy is the closest
thing psychology has to a chemical
equation
who wrote that Adam mastrioni
in sub stack it's very nice I'll send
you the article it's very nice and it's
consistent with what uh Adam Smith says
in uh his theory of moral sentiments he
says when you have a really horrible
trip and think about a horrible trip you
know for us a horrible trip is the plane
sat on the tarmac for four hours they
didn't let us get off and then we didn't
end up taking on we had to come back we
lost our bags blah blah blah blah Adam
Smith got dysentery yeah I don't know
what he got and of course the horse you
know stepped on his foot I I don't know
what it was 1759 but uh and disadaries
that's bad uh but Smith says when you
have a bad trip
when people are bad to you and things go
wrong and are unexpected he said there's
a certain type of person who just who
comes and whines about it they come to
other friends ah this was so horrible
you can't believe what happened to me it
was so unfair why me yeah the plane was
et cetera Etc and what Smith says is no
one sympathizes with you actually
uh one reason being of course is because
it's a first world problem really
nothing horrible happens to you and
that's in those stories it's just your
expectations get frustrated and what
Smith says which is very consistent with
Adam astroni Smith says you're better
off making a joke out of it
and you know some of my brother's best
comedy routines he has many but some of
the best ones are about the trips that
go wrong and it's great advice you know
I get bit by a cat about a week and a
half ago a street cat here in Jerusalem
I it's a it's a pretty good stand up for
team at the time didn't feel like one
you know I'm watching blood run down my
hand I'm worried about rabies I'm
thinking I'm gonna die
by the way I think I'm outside the
window I think I'm good I'm gonna be
okay but for a bit there I was kind of
anxious but I didn't tell people about
it you can't believe what happened to me
I can't believe they're all these Street
cats here said I tried to make it
humorous and I think that's great advice
for life
what about John Stuart Mill what did you
learn about a life well lived from him
so
um
this comes from
Dan Gilbert the great uh Harvard
psychologist he and I don't agree about
this but I love the examples I used in
the book
so Mill said it's better to be a
philosopher unsatisfied
than a pig satisfied
and that's a deep question is that true
is that true statement is ignorance
Bliss yeah is the unexamined knife life
really not worth living is a colleague
of mine here at Shalom said wants to be
I know I know a lot of people with an
unexamined life they seem pretty happy
I could argue the opposite you know
philosophers are kind of morbid and
depressed and and so on uh and Dan
Gilbert's Insight which I don't agree
with but it's an interesting claim is
that uh Miller was wrong he says the
only thing that matters is how much
pleasure you have in life and if you
swim in a pool of placid water for 23
hours a day and for one hour a day you
step out of the pool and go like that's
my whole life all I'm doing is swimming
I should be ashamed of myself it's okay
for an hour you're unhappy but for 23
hours you're happy and the 23 hours that
you're happy you're not thinking about
the the philosopher saying that's it
that's all there is to life and for the
one area of the philosophy you're
neglecting the pleasure you get from
swimming so all you've got is is how
many hours there are if there's more
hours of swimming than guilt swim
I think that's wrong I don't agree I
think um when you're in the pool after a
while some of the thrill is gone because
you think this is my whole life of
swimming is just enjoying myself merely
and so I think there's a lot more to say
about I say in the book but the um it's
a very interesting way to think about
framing how we think about where we want
ourselves to be
just gonna have fun nothing can't really
say anything wrong with that
um you know is it really true that a
more meaningful life is a better life I
don't know
people seem to think so a lot of smart
people seem to argue so a lot of signals
going on there yeah yeah it could be
yeah it's true hard to know but it's
worth thinking about
I first heard this as uh posited as a
debate between the two great danes of
psychology Kahneman and Gilbert because
they stand on opposite sides of the
fence with regards to this I've come to
believe that this is temperament
dependent I have some friends who live
in the now who are much more hedonic
than I am who are much less
introspective they ruminate less and
they would be I don't know whether they
would be completely but they would be
more likely to be the person that's
Happy having the cocktail on the Lilo in
the pool right
for me because of the amount of time
that I tend to spend reflecting
introspecting ruminating I know that to
me a life well lived is one which in
retrospect I'm glad that I lived I very
much am assessing reassessing the things
that I did and then my current degree of
self-worth is based off the back of that
reflection whereas somebody else very
much may be able to and this is the
question right is ignorance bliss now
you also get into something similar I'm
very interesting I'm going to see Jordan
Peterson tonight in Manchester he's a
good friend the first time I ever saw
him was five years ago in Manchester at
the same venue and someone asked him a
question that he used to take questions
from Twitter he does a q a at the end he
still may do and um someone asked him
basically the depth of my Consciousness
causes me to suffer is ignorance Bliss I
wish that I could regress back from this
and Jordan's answer basically was once
you have opened that box once you have
seen what is inside you've peered into
the red pill you've begun to examine the
life there is no going back and his
argument was that the only way out is
through he used this analogy of taking
more of the thing that poisons you until
you turn it into a tonic that allows you
to girdle the world around you I mean
it's in uh typically apocalyptic Jordan
Peterson patriarchal finger finger
wagging tone but I read and I've I've
kept that way that's a five-year-old
two minute monologue that I've kept with
me because it's a question I ask myself
a lot about you know this sort of bloody
hell would life not be simpler if it was
just simpler uh and then on the reverse
of that you think well
if you can learn to love the process of
analysis there is such deep pleasure
that can be got from working out how
things link together and knowing that
there is a a bit of a heavy weight to
Bear here like I had to do a good bit of
a lift to get myself around my own
incumbent nature and yet on the other
side of it it's so it's really really
satisfying and I thought that that
linked in a little bit with Adam Adam
Smith's uh example well when you're
talking about your friends are a little
more hedonistic than you are I was
thinking oh yeah they're each one of
them is as happy as a clown
an expression that we use it's a very
strange expression when you think about
it
can't imagine a clam is that happy but I
think what it means is it's easy to
please a clam just Pleasant in water
you're good
and um I don't know whether it's because
I'm a religious person or my cultural
upbringing but
it kind of inspired him more than a clam
I think many do nothing wrong with you
know not not judgment yeah clam life is
great for clams uh and so as you say I
think it is a temperament it's partly a
temperament issue
[Music]
um
your example of of
um doing the hard work I think I think
most people who do hard work and find a
reward at the end uh find that
meaningful
um
I think it depends what the reward is
sometimes it's self-actualization
sometimes it's the sense of command
sometimes it's helping others by
something you've created with a group of
people through a set of sacrifices and
hard work
um but you know when I list
the things that are deeply meaningful to
me
um most of them aren't the clam area you
know I've had a lot of fun in my life I
don't look I'm not a you know H.O
Mankins not an exact quote but just of
it is menkin said that you know
puritanism is the haunting fear that
someone somewhere is having a good time
I love a good time uh all kinds of good
times there's many different ones some
with a group of people some with a close
friend some with your family
um they're all good they're great
they're part of the important texture of
day-to-day life and they're not to be
looked down on or sneered at and many of
them are are Transcendent through the
Sublimity of them but at the same time
there are many other things that are
part of life that that extend past just
the moment you were alluded to them
earlier a minute ago
and um you know as I I write in the book
that
as you get older bittersweet chocolate
is better than sweet chocolate you know
when you're a child sweet it's all you
want and when you're an adult things
that are bittersweet they're a little
more painful that come with sacrifice
um there are the things that I think we
value more steeply often
there's a very interesting point to be
raised here around age I think and
wisdom and um there is a an element of
this that Confucius talks about so he
says uh in the early stages of training
an aspiring Confucian gentleman needs to
memorize entire shelves of archaic texts
learn the precise angle at which to Bow
and learn the lengths of the steps with
which he is to enter a room his sitting
mat must always be perfectly straight
all of this rigor and restraint however
is ultimately aimed at producing a
cultivated but nonetheless genuine form
of spontaneity indeed the process of
training is not considered complete
until the individual has passed
completely beyond the Need For Thought
or effort one of the problems that we
encounter is that
when most people begin any sort of
pursuit
that are reflective and probably the
sort of people that are listening to
this podcast they will rely on cognitive
horsepower to get them through these
challenges they will have Frameworks
they will have principles and so so on
and so forth that they apply to these
situations now over time what you
realize is that your subconscious
embodied experience whatever it is that
you want to call it is able to aggregate
all of your experiences in a much more
effective way than rationally trying to
go so what got you here won't get you
there but because we use uh like memetic
Evolution to work out well this in the
past worked therefore I should continue
to do it it's very difficult to let go
of that and then the ruling that I'm
thinking about here is that when you are
younger relying on Frameworks seems like
a smarter idea because you don't have as
much experience right what do you what
are you drawing on and also another
element to consider here is I always
thought when I was younger and I still
do now my my ability to do sort of um
hyperbolic discounting or to basically
just have such a small sphere of
understanding around the tactics I'm
using now are going to be the ones that
I'll use forever
they're not you periodize your life you
go through a period everyone that I know
went through a period of being obsessed
about productivity and and having the
note-taking external brain app and they
were pomodoroing 25 minutes on and five
minutes after getting things done yes
yeah they were David allening their way
through the world and then they
transcend that after a while but I
remember when I was doing that that this
is going to be my Pursuit for the rest
of time I'm going to be completely just
dedicated to productivity and then now I
I just have like a minimum viable system
I'm like look it's could it be better
yeah but is it enough yeah and now I
move on to the next thing and you
aggregate through all of these different
bits my point being in the beginning
relying on principles you know the stuff
that you guys talk about on your show
and learning the more rational
utilitarian foundations this is how
things get underpinned
and then allowing yourself to ameliorate
that how does it just get mixed in with
the soup of everything else that I do
and the good [ __ ] sticks the stuff that
I like will stick about and the stuff
that I don't use will just fade away and
that's fine and I think it also gets on
to what you said earlier on about
relieving some of the pressure it's like
look you're gonna let some stuff go
maybe you're not going to be able to
recall all of the different elements of
David Allen's GTD method as effectively
as you could 20 years ago but it doesn't
matter because you are now onto bigger
and better things and I think that that
balance between Young
procedural old uh spontaneous wisdom
embodied whatever you want to call it I
think that that's a dynamic that
increasingly I think people should be
aware of
it's a great Insight
um
I think when I when I say to people
don't use cost-benefit analysis or at
least be aware of the shortcomings which
I talk about at length
people then say well what's the
alternative going with your gut
and I wouldn't suggest going with your
gut generally in most situations
although I give some examples in the
book of where seemingly rational people
looked like they went with their gut uh
but I I suggest they had other things
going on there
but I do think when you talk to very
successful people
particularly in the financial and
business world you ask them how they
make decisions they will often say at
least I've heard it many many times I
just use my intuition
which is a form of going with your God
it's like kind of like think about it
and I look I see the path
and on the surface that sounds like just
going with your God it's just a wild
guess I try something I just see what's
uh what I feel like but it's really more
than it's a lot more than that it would
it's what you were talking about and you
said it very well that as you get older
you accumulate evidence
that your self processes in ways you
don't see rationally
um and you got to trust some of that
it's not your gut it's the accumulated
experience of living
and you know I always wonder
you know these lists of what I want my
20 years what I've wanted my 20 year old
self to know and
I'm not sure my 20 year old self was
well I know my 20 year old son was not a
good listener
um so I don't think my 20 year old self
would have heard that advice much and it
I don't know if young people in general
can hear wisdom from older people
uh like you just passed on
some can it's a temperament issue I
think people vary in how their ability
to to absorb lessons but what you're
really saying is that when you're
younger you're going to need to realize
you're going to make decisions
differently when you get older and
there's nothing wrong with that because
you'll have different powers
it's pretty cool it's a very big problem
that we have that a lot of the people
who especially now in the world of
podcasting and YouTube
the people that have a lot of status and
or Reach online are people who have been
through a lot of situations that young
people haven't and young people are
trying to model young behavior on old
people's advice yeah that's interesting
doesn't work doesn't work you can take a
photo of the top of the mountain and say
to people look here's what it looks like
at the top uh by the way there's this
hole on the right hand side you need to
avoid that and the ladder's a little bit
rickety so the fourth rung up you should
avoid that one and people go yeah yeah
that sounds great and yeah taking notes
the whole world they still decide to
have to go up the mountain themselves in
order to be able to see what's at the
top of it and this is
part of I have a an Insight maybe that a
good amount an embarrassingly large
amount of the wisdom that we think is
self-generated through our introspection
and our self-work comes along for the
ride as a byproduct of just getting
older and that's like as someone that
loves an agents like Sovereign
experience
terrifies me because I think oh God how
much of the time that I'm spending now
that being said I take pleasure from the
the introspection and the work in any
case so it's kind of a moot point but
some of us some of it's a narrative
fallacy right you're just you're just
convincing yourself of something that
just looks it's on the surface it's uh
it's like the uh you know my favorite
example is the guy playing the video
game
and he hasn't put any money in it yet
doesn't realize that it's got an
automatic version before you put the
money in that you're doing and in the
case of uh you know you're pushing the
buttons for Space Invaders for those old
enough to remember what it was and you
see things
firing and you think ships rocket ships
of the enemy going down you think I'm
doing great but you haven't even put the
money in is It's Just an Illusion so
some of that going on
what about having well I have to presume
that having robust principles and and
hard rules that scale across multiple
situations must be one of the solutions
that people can have here not having to
approach each individual challenge with
the expected value calculator of this
one something a firmer place for people
to stand must be a good way to uh
expedite this
yeah so I have some of those in the book
uh and there's some nice there's some
thoughtful people on Twitter and wisdom
literature and elsewhere who have some
of these rules you know one the one I
focus on in a chapter is called
privilege of principles that a lot of
times keeping your principles keeping
your values living by them is going to
be costly
and you're not going to get much
pleasure from the idea that you stuck to
your principles you're just going to
miss out on something you thought you
could have done if you were a little
less honest then I used the example of
returning a wallet where no one sees you
finding it on the street you find a wall
on the street but it'd be great if you
could keep it and not feel guilty but I
you know I suggest to it might be a good
thing to Aspire to be a person who would
feel guilty even if you don't feel
guilty now and these kind of ideas of
you know ethical principles mostly I
think they come up a lot of work and in
situations where
you know there's always a financial
temptation to do certain things that are
you know in your heart or wrong
um don't compromise you know economics
suggests oh the bigger the gain the more
likely you are to sell by your
principles and I suggest don't just
never sell much better rule let's have a
rule don't go well in this case it's
probably worth it after kids life should
stay steal the bread yes
um that's a different kind of principle
then besides honesty is to keep your
children alive but in general those
conflicts don't happen it's usually
about your pleasure versus doing the
right thing you should do the right
thing you'll be you'll lead a better
life but not a better life you're a
fuller human being uh but you will have
some pain so might not be the right
thing you see this online a lot in the
online content creation worlds that
there are people who will succumb to
audience Capture One
piece of content at a time yeah yeah and
the problem is when you sell your
integrity you can't buy it back it is a
one-way Street good line yeah yeah it's
so true it only goes in One Direction
and
although you don't have the external
accountability
of the audience fact checking you about
whether you did give that wallet back or
not
there is something you know whether it's
the Daemon whether it's the subconscious
whether it's the whatever right there's
something that's keeping track and I I
remember I was a club promoter for a
long time I run nightclubs uh in the UK
and I I wasn't the most honest person I
wasn't just stealing money I wasn't
doing anything like that but I just
compromised my own opinion to try and
please other people I want it to be
liked so I would tell them what I
thought they wanted to hear yeah and
there was this there was this ambient
sort of trepidation around what how I
would feel and I think it's because I I
was always fearful that I would be found
out for not being the person that I said
I was so there was ambient anxiety the
whole time just yeah you know infusing
whatever I did yeah and
on the other side of that now you know
maybe not being the same party guy or
whatever that I was that wouldn't
appease people in that same sort of way
first off I found that authenticity is
much more seductive and attractive to
people than whatever version of persona
you think that they want to see because
they can see through it and secondly
your degree of self love self-respect
whatever you want to refer to it as
really should be prioritized but above
most other things there are a few things
that I think should go above you said
you know steal the bread if your child's
hungry and dying yeah cool
there's not many there's not many
situations that I think that should go
above that yeah I I yeah I I agree with
that I I do I wanted to say I think
Redemption is possible it's hard to get
your integrity back but it is possible
and I do think that a lot of people who
are good at deceiving others or have to
deal with that temptation of they can be
in a inauthentic and get away with it
which um seems like a blessing but it's
probably a curse it's an extra degree of
difficulty on their life yeah but what
about so obviously one of the issues
that we have here is that
the these large decisions have an
anxiety of uncertainty around them uh
how should people avoid being crushed
under the pressure of these big
decisions that they need to make well I
think it's helpful to start off by
recognizing that as a human being you
have a strong desire for certainty
that the uncertainty and the anxiety it
produces is very normal
um
and to be able to be aware of that as
opposed to just being anxious is a huge
step forward
uh I try to relieve some of the
uncertainty by pointing out that it's
inevitable we talked about this earlier
you're making a leap into the dark the
fact you don't know where you're where
you're gonna land is nothing to be
embarrassed about or ashamed of or
um and and should think of it as a
mistake
um I also talk about the virtues of
settling and the pressure we put
ourselves to buy the best
wicking underwear the best fill in the
blank using putting the oh the Great
these wire cutter recommendations with
my Amazon thing and I've got this other
site that checks on whether Amazon
recommendation you know the stars are
real or whether they're done by a bot or
the you know
um
just it's okay so you don't have to have
the best one it's not usually isn't a
best wanted there's the best one for you
that might be the best one for the
average person you're not the average
person some
it fascinates to me that that we are
anxious about those things and I do
think that some self-awareness about
that is goes part way toward reducing
the um the pain of it what did you learn
from Bill Belichick I know that you
looked at him
yeah so Bill Belichick's an interesting
example he's widely regarded as one of
the greatest football coaches of all
time uh what I suggest is he's very
aware of his own limitations uh
most important thing one of the most
important things not the but one of the
most important things a coach or general
manager is a football is pick players
for from college who are going to play
for your team
uh bill has been around for a long time
he's learned that that's really hard to
do well and it's interesting why it's
hard to do well there is hard data on
every player they know how fast they run
how much weight they can lift
um how many yards they ran for what
competition level of competition they
played against have an immense amount of
statistic statistical information about
these players and it's not vaguely
enough and one of the reasons not enough
is that each player then comes into a
specific situation and belcheck has puts
a lot of pressure on his players to
adapt to his system and to communicate
with each other and therefore the per he
can't really know how good that person
is going to be until they're in the
actual Crucible vampire game and exactly
and so
he's realized that
his success ratio is small so his best
bet is just have a large denominator
pick a lot of players and some of them
he will discover through the process of
testing them in preseason whether
they're going to be good players or not
probably get one player per round so how
could he get more picks and the answer
is well you can trade the higher rated
picks the second first or third round
picks for multiple picks in the choices
in the sixth and seventh and and fourth
rounds and he does that quite often and
I I don't know if this is true by the
way I I presume he does it more often
than others and I presume he does it I
you know it's just it's my impression
it's a very casual uh fan of of the
Patriots his team uh that he's often
doing that and what he is famous for
though is finding really good players
from later rounds Tom Brady being the
most famous example
um and often players that weren't
drafted he has chosen a player who was
not drafted uh meaning he signed them
after the draft was over the selection
process and they they've made the team
he's also famous for cutting people that
he thought were really good that weren't
he doesn't go oh I'm going to look
stupid I wasted this High ranked pick he
goes they're not a good player
um so he's a fascinating example by the
way he's in he was mentored in economics
at Wesleyan and I think he understands
trade-offs really really well which is
one of the things you learn as an
economist and if you're a successful
football coach I think you understand
them also so there's a guy called Eddie
Jones He Is England Rugby's head coach
and it is the World Cup for rugby 2023
coming up so there is a good amount of
pressure on him he has coached Australia
Japan and England and in between that he
went and he was a PE teacher of 13 14 15
year old boys so he has literally been
from the lowest of the low to the elite
in terms of rugby and I had him on the
show and got to have a breakfast with
him while he was in Newcastle which is
where I am now I got her breakfast with
him but about a year ago and um first
off I noticed that he paid a lot of
attention a bunch of other things
he asked me a ton of questions and then
I wanted to ask him about what was the
selection criteria for his players
because he travels around the country
watching Club games Premier League club
games of rugby and he's maybe got three
or four players on the pitch who he's
assessing are these guys going to be
right and I was like also what are you
looking for
and uh
the answer that he gave was just nothing
that I thought so he said he arrives
before well before the game starts and
what he's looking for has almost nothing
to do with the ball handling skills
their speed their strength their power
any of that what he looks at is what's
their relationship like with the ground
staff when they walk out onto the pitch
what's their relationship like with the
other players when they're determining
what drills to to run before the game
begins once the game begins if they're
winning how does their body language
change if they're losing how does their
body language change one of the key
things that he looked at was how often
are they looking to the coaches for what
to do next and how often are they
deciding themselves said that when he
went to Japan he spoke to the only
successful Japanese team which was the
female volleyball team uh Japan wasn't
having a good period with regards to the
Olympics and he went and spoke to the
coach who'd been relatively new and he
said what did you do some successful
criteria here
in volleyball I didn't know this in
volleyball the coach is very close to
the edge of the court and that means
that the players can interact with the
coach pretty quickly I guess similar to
football except for the fact that the
pitch is you know one tenth of the size
or one 50th of the size so he's able to
speak to them and the coach immediately
cut any player that asked him for advice
now that seems like a perhaps a bit more
of a brutal hard and fast yes but the
principle I think came through that
Eddie says that the absolute Elite of
sport you want players that are
self-sufficient you want players who are
not going to have that internal State
too affected by the um current position
of the game because that means they're
going to be down when you're down and up
when you're up and there's this
flip-flopping around and he wanted to
see how they interacted with the
training staff with the ground staff
with the coaches with the physios with
the other players I just thought that
that was again beautiful again similar
to to bill you know he's he's looking
for the intangibles because yeah what
what is the return for this vampire
problem the unknown unknowns and how you
need to bayesianly update and you can't
predict that updating is there is a
return for that I think it's the term is
uh the unknown unknowns of the Bayesian
no I don't think there's a term yeah you
know what I mean that should be one you
should the vampire we can refer to it as
the vampire problem for now well look
Russ Roberts ladies and gentlemen Russ
this has been great uh I really really
appreciate it I appreciate your Artful
form of uh looking at economics through
the uh transcended Sage that you've
obviously now managed to to get yourself
close to if people want to check out the
stuff that you do online where should
they go I I'm on Twitter as econ talker
uh they can go to econtalk.org JCC by my
podcast or any place where podcasts are
found and I archive all my work at
russroberts.info amazing Russ I
appreciate you thank you a lot of fun
Chris talk to you soon what's happening
people thank you very much for tuning in
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe
peace
[Music]